Twitter's a controversial place with a
lot of controversial opinions but let's
see what they do with medical info Mela
my doctor thinks I'm hot he said fever
but I'll take it
a fever is about 100 point 3 degrees
Fahrenheit a lot of my patients come in
and say they have a fever because
they're running 99.5
but that's not a fever technically
speaking you are hot though mami cusses
found out at my doctor's appointment
that the disturbing voices I've been
hearing non-stop on coach children Bill
Murray
did Bill Murray tweet this I hate when
I'm on the treadmill and my hand
accidentally hits the stop button I have
to get off and eat a bacon grilled
cheese
don't hit the stop button unless it's an
emergency of course and don't get a
bacon grilled cheese first date her I'm
really only interested in inner beauty
me oh I see
second date me so I scheduled us for
colonoscopy
that's funny that's not the inner beauty
that you want to see because I will tell
you unless you do really good colon prep
which means drinking that stuff that
makes you clear out the colon is not a
pretty place to be
taming Fred Savage I don't know who Fred
savages me donating body to science
science donates my body to God will
that's not how it works first of all
everyone should highly recommend it by
me become an organ donor all the myths
out there about doctors not caring about
you because you're an organ donor and
they'll let you die it's all nonsense
nonsense when I'm working in the ER I
have no idea who's an organ donor who's
not only once the patient passes do we
even begin to look for that information
and we don't donate the bodies to go do
it I found out it takes 42 muscles to
frown so I went ahead and canceled my
gym Bishop I don't know it's 42 muscles
but I know it takes more muscles to
frown than to smile that's why I'm
always smiling because I'm lazy
Rodney Lacroix I wonder if he owns the
water
rich doctor do you exercise me yes smoke
no never drink yes how often for kids
heavily God I long and love for those
honest conversations as a family
medicine doc you're talking to someone
who stressed out they're not so excited
to be at a doctor's office because they
have a million other things to do but
you just have this like connection where
they tell you about their life you
understand their struggles you help them
you try and make their life not only a
little bit healthier but a little bit
more fruitful so they get more out of it
they give to the world they give to
themselves genetics lab me once designer
baby please doctor it's not like that
you me please remove the pooping
functions doctor what no you can't me
give it wings and flamethrowers doctor
mmm me I'm gonna call her Claire sounds
like they're building a transformer more
than they are making a designer baby
that is literally not how it works your
baby will need to cry your baby will
need to poop in fact if it didn't have
those functions you'll have a bigger
problem with your baby just saying maybe
I took that too seriously you know
you're a nurse if you've been telling
stories in a restaurant and had someone
at another table throw up I think that's
just like being in the medical
professional in general sometimes I'm
telling stories to my friends and
they're like Mike we're eating and I'm
like true poop jokes don't work when
you're eating dessert Jesse
doctor do you exercise me thinking of
the arm curls to get the chips from the
bag to my mouth yes
daily hmm if you actually do like a
strong isometric attraction right here
that could be exercise but I don't know
many people who eat chips like that if
you do why on shell at a doctor
appointment step up on the scale
jokingly do I have to know what how have
I gone this long without knowing this
much I mean everything when you go to a
doctor's office is an option unless
you're going for like a work physical or
some kind of clearance but in general
when you go you have a patient Bill of
Rights anything you don't want to do
even though like well
try and recommend why you should do it
you don't have to that's like the beauty
of medicine we work together as a team
if you're uncomfortable with something
maybe don't say I don't want to do it
state that you're uncomfortable and
perhaps hear the doctor's explanation of
why it's recommended you never realize
how squeaky your shoes are until you
walk into the room of a sleeping patient
nurse problems nurse life I don't know
what it is
hospitals are extra echoey why so I got
a text from the doctor asking if my crap
was properly hydrated turns out he
actually wrote CPAP and no I'm not
adjusting to bifocals well those of you
who don't know CPAP is continuous
positive airway pressure it's the thing
that you people wear around their nose
at night it's like a big contraption
that lays up the side of their bed it
basically keeps your airway open so that
when you have sleep apnea your airway
doesn't collapse you wake up like
snoring because you actually weren't
breathing it's not so comfortable to
wear but I will say there are things on
the horizon to make this whole process a
lot simpler me I feel like a pizza party
should refer to pizzas having a party
humans having pizza at a party should
just be a party with pizza does that
make sense to you therapist I think we
should meet more often I think that is
natural curiosity that makes you
eccentric and fun and interesting to be
around Madi MSN you know it's gonna be a
hash tag bad day when the scrub machine
gives you two pans no shits going
shirtless for those of you who don't
know there are now like scrub X machines
I forgot the name of the brand where you
literally punch in like your employee ID
or scan your badge and it feeds you your
scrubs for the day you could put them on
but sometimes they make mistakes they
give you wrong sizes sometimes it gives
you two pants and no shirt and that's a
struggle because to get it fixed like
you need to go find someone and if
you're busy and it's a shift hey do you
want to hang out sure I'm free October
30 second twenty fifty one let's plan
something for that med student problems
oh my god I remember when I was on the
ICU block and I would be working six
days a week
call Q two which means every other day
means you come in at like 5:00 a.m. you
leave at 9:00 p.m. every other day just
like imagine how brutal that is you have
to wake up at like 3:30 for get to the
hospital work all day get home at night
wake up against
like all you did was work and sleep
during the ICU block your friends were
like where did you go this last month
and you're like I see you there like you
see me don't know ice intensive care you
jk I'll get it taken nine out of ten
doctors recommended diet rich and lean
protein and vegetables and one of the
ten doctors is a stakeholder in the
berry actually those you who don't know
by the way a bariatric sleeve is a
surgery that you can get in order to
shrink the size of your stomach which
basically encourages you to not eat so
you lose a lot of weight quickly other
names for this is a stomach bypass
stomach stapling procedure and gastric
bypass all sorts of names but these
types of bariatric surgeries actually
have really good evidence working
long-term for those who are really obese
I'm not talking about if you're 1015
pounds overweight I'm talking morbid
obesity where the obesity is presenting
an imminent threat to your life CT scan
patient doc you're sure this is safe
just a little radiation right me from a
mile away behind some bulletproof glass
a wall that's 45 feet thick and a full
suit of lead uh-huh please hold
now look CT scans absolutely expose you
to a dose of radiation the benefits of
getting a CT scan in an emergency or
when there's a true medical condition
that we're trying to evaluate are
outweighed by the risks meaning that
it's more beneficial to do the scan and
expose yourself to some potential
radiation that being said doing CT scans
unnecessarily is really bad and as a
patient okay you'll get one CT scan but
as the doctor or the tech that's doing
the exam you're doing dozens of these a
day so you'd be exposed to a ton of
radiation so you better get 45 feet away
by a 45 foot wall with a suit of lead
doctor how do you practice self-care
meet
pillows doctor pillows by sleeping on
them me know by screaming into them you
know what I wouldn't even judge one of
my patients came in and they said they
get a lot of happiness or their their
emotions out by screaming into a pillow
that's that's awesome I think I get a
lot of my anger out and work out my
issues when I'm like punching a punching
bag you know
and to each their own there is a
surprising lack of YouTube videos
detailing how to perform self surgeries
for in Creole hernia yeah because you
shouldn't perform surgery on yourself
it's really that simple
there was a story of a doctor who
perform surgery on themselves I think
like Antarctica because there was no
access to medicine and he performed an
appendectomy on himself I'm gonna tell
the story in a video cuz like it's a
crazy story and you got it here if
you're down let me know in the comments
no idea daddy blog five-year-old where's
the scissors meet five-year-old I'm
playing doctor
mmm cute on the dog takes back scissor
there that one was about you I would
never use scissors on you I would never
use scissors on you you sleepy
he's a sleepy bear today we go you guys
go ahead well that's an aggressive you
[Music]